we begin this half-hour with some
airlines saying they are reviewing their
passenger compensation policies when
flights are overbooked this follows last
Sunday's incident when a United Airlines
passenger was forcibly removed from a
plane but the review is also forcing
carriers to look at other practices
here's Kris Van Cleave an estimated 2.4
million passengers a day are expected to
fly this spring that's a new record of 4
percent from last year making for a busy
Easter weekend
for me that included a flight home I
spent a long week this is our fifth
Airport in four cities in about four
days heading back to Washington and it
looks like we're on time but April has
already been a long month for the
airlines
last week Delta canceled more than 4,000
flights due to storms and computer
problems
stranding tens of thousands of Flyers
and costing the airline an estimated 125
million dollars and the violent removal
of dr. David Dow from a united flight at
Chicago O'Hare on Sunday touched off a
worldwide firestorm of criticism for the
airline and renewed focus on how fliers
are treated in skies that don't always
feel so friendly passenger tally ku sort
had opened my eyes up to some of the
things that the airlines can do that we
weren't aware of to counter all the bad
press three of the nation's biggest
carriers scrambled to change their
policies Delta announced its upping the
amount it will pay for passengers to
give up their seats on overbooked
flights gate agents can offer up to two
thousand dollars and supervisors can
dish out nearly 10 grand American
Airlines is now promising it will never
bump a passenger once they're seated and
United who said Sunday's controversial
removal was actually to clear a seat for
an airline employee issued a new rule
requiring crew members to be booked at
least 60 minutes prior to the flight
time these new rules aimed ease flier
concern and prevent a repeat of this
humne passenger mary anne mcclain i
actually joked with my daughter on the
way here to hear it about I hope I got
on the plane and kept my seat for CBS
this morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington guess the airline's got the
message
yeah it's too bad that it took that
video to get the message to them yeah